you did mention the the non-existent
climate crisis and that it's it's a ploy
for World control and this is what I we
hear this argument from people a lot and
you you and I had a few messages about
my Oxford speech that you understand how
I feel about you know if we're if we're
being told that that you know Carbon is
the problem why are we doing things that
don't seem to really do anything about
that so so I get what you're saying but
I always get wary when people get into
the sort of like there's a a group of
people who secretly have an agenda uh
now we see with the Davos people
whatever they all believe this stuff and
they all think it's important and and
because they think it's important they
think a global problem requires Global
Solutions correct but are you saying
that these aren't just a bunch of you
know slightly deluded well-intentioned
people but actually they don't believe
the thing that they're saying in the
first place some of them do the less
intelligent ones do um yeah the John
Curry's and the Al gors and uh
um you know and you got some True
Believers you know jilliance has you
know been knocked heads with her a few
times
um of the financial times but I also I
also disagree Constantine when you said
um you know talk about secret Cabana and
you didn't quite put it that way but
that was sort of uh you know aren't we
in the conspiracy theory land it's not a
secret I can name them all you know it's
Christina hours and Johnny Owen and Tim
Gaither and Mark Carney probably the
number one villain in the whole thing
um uh you know the the Tim Cook Jeff
Bezos you're the heads of the major tech
companies Mark Zuckerberg uh the Davos
crowd but but more than that uh and they
totally get it these are you know these
are smart people in addition to being
immensely powerful but they want this
because sorry Jim what do they want they
well what they want and and I talk about
this in my book the road to ruin a 2016
book that wrote the rule and I explained
this in great detail probably being 10
years ahead of your time is it when it
comes true everyone forgot you send it
but pick up that book and you'll you'll
get the blueprint
um look what they want in nutshell is
World Government World money World
taxation with a small group in control
that's what they want the question is
how do you get there the answer is and
and Carl popper explained this uh 70 80
years ago and George Soros adopted it uh
it's called Uh piecemeal social
engineering it's like slicing a salamity
salami don't take the whole thing it
wants to slice slice slice people don't
notice or give yourself enough time and
you'll eventually get to where you want
to be so the Euro was a big step in that
direction uh because it no more Lira no
more chocolate no more pesetos uh French
francs
um and now you know NAFTA it was a big
step in that direction you know more you
know no more borders so they want to
eliminate borders they want to eliminate
different kinds of money the uh the
Central Bank digital currencies even if
you do it you know this is cbdc Euro
it's not it's not a cryptocurrency by
the way it's the message traffic is
encrypted it is digital but it's not a
cryptocurrency because there's a single
Ledger controlled by the government they
can see what you're doing this is the
ultimate
um social control tool
where are they traveling how are they
traveling what are they eating what are
they consuming on the platform so
individual carbon footprint tracker stay
tuned we don't have it operational yet
but this is something that we're working
on
so right now I'm in an airport I want a
candy bar I go to a retail place I buy a
candy bar I use a credit card the
merchant how does he get paid well he
sells that receivable to somebody called
a merchant acquirer these are factoring
businesses that buy up hundreds of
millions of dollars of receivables so
the merchant gets paid then the merchant
acquirer delivers it to Mastercard or
VISA he gets paid MasterCard Visa
distributes it to the issuing Banks they
get paid the bank sends me a bill and I
pay the bank okay why do we need five
intermediaries and three percent
discount three percent of fees for me to
buy a candy bar uh so the essential Bank
digital currency where you have a single
Ledger you know QR code on your on your
smartphone no intermediaries
um it's better faster cheaper and that's
true that's actually true they always
sell stuff by giving you the benefits
they never tell you the other side the
other side is
um oh no I'm in a bookstore I buy the
new book by Rhonda sanus you know well
right now that's between me and
MasterCard you need under the Fourth
Amendment you need a subpoena and a
warrant to get that information from
MasterCard and if you're not a wrongdoor
they should be able to get it but with
essential Bank digital currency the uh
the government knows that they know I
bought a book by around the sentence
they know I gave a contribution to Elise
stefanik who's the number three
Republican in the house
um they know I I travel to you know
Florida you know Red State whatever me
and then you combine what I just said
that ledger with um artificial
intelligence with the GPT uh generative
pre-trained Transformer technology you
got a Target on your back but that
information which the government will
now have firsthand they're not stealing
it you're giving it to them by using
their Central Bank digital currency
combined with
um uh GPT uh artificial intelligence
technology they can develop a profile of
you and go back to
um Joe Biden's speech in Independence
Hall in September uh 2022 just ahead of
the midterm elections are directed by
Lenny rufinstall I mean might as well
have been right every everything that
they use that she invented at the
Nuremberg rallies you know putting the
leader up on the pedestal she was the
one who dug trenches put the cameras in
the trenches so you'd be looking up even
higher at the leader the vertical lights
the blood red backdrop everything about
that the art direction that speech was
right out of Nuremberg and you know
she's a great art director
um and and more uh so but what if I
didn't say he said half the country are
enemies of the people he said not all
your Republicans but you Maggie
Republicans while that's charity the
Republican Party
um our enemies of the people so now you
got Biden telling you you're An Enemy of
the State you got the government knowing
actually it's kind of thought control
because I using inference I can tell by
what you're reading what you're buying
what you're attending Etc kind of what
you're thinking uh combine that with
artificial intelligence and GPT
technology and now you got a Target on
your back and expect a knock on the door
from the FBI goon squads so that's
that's awesome
that's where we're going yeah
foreign